(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] So.
- [Alanis] I know.
- It's a very excited audience.
It's a great show today.
They're very excited.
I'm still like reeling.
I know that your show that
I went to was a while back
but it was the greatest night ever.
Anyway, I saw her at the
Bowl and it was incredible.
So, you gotta go do that.
But I just, I am also
a fan of "Bridgerton".
And I know that they
use "You Oughta Know".
- Yes.
- Like they use like songs
we all know and love.
- In the show. Yes.
- [Kelly] And they use it in the show.
- Yes. So beautifully.
- [Kelly] But then you
like re-imagined it.
- Yes, so I was.
- So what were fans thinking about that?
- I don't know. You tell me.
- Oh, I love any, like literally,
I love every single album,
everything you...
You're one of those people that focus,
'cause I'm a lyrics person.
- Ah, there you go.
- [Kelly] So I really love.
- Ding ding.
- Yeah, so that's, yeah.
- [Alanis] Yeah.
- You're like one of the
reasons why I'm a writer, so.
And a lot of us.
I'm just gonna gush the whole interview.
- Oh, my gosh.
- But no, but it was amazing.
But was it cool because it's, I guess,
that song was released so long ago
that like now people
that maybe didn't hear it back in the day.
- Yes, it's new, essentially.
- That's kind of, it's like a new life
- Yeah. This evolution thing happens.
We get older and...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- New generations come
in and there's, you know
they can be exposed to everything.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which is exciting.
- Yeah.
- [Alanis] Yeah.
- But it's interesting.
Do you find it interesting
how you write songs
and it's coming from, I feel
like a lot yours are personal.
- [Alanis] Mm, yeah.
- And then people
perceive them differently?
Like I'll be in like a meet and greet.
- Yes.
- And I'll be like wait, what?
And they'll think a song like I wrote.
- The interpretation.
- Yeah, the interpretation.
- Yes. That happens a lot.
I remember when I wrote a
song called "Hands Clean",
someone came up to me and they said,
I love that story you tell about this
where you're in love with
your lesbian teacher.
And that song is so beautiful.
The dedication to her is so amazing.
And I just thought, well,
which teacher was that?
- Did you then go, are you in love
with your lesbian teacher?
- [Alanis] Is there some
projection going on?
- Yeah, is there some projection,
'cause that's...no one got that
from that, just that person.
- But the point of it is just that once,
I mean, when I write it for me,
it's beautifully self-indulgent
in a way that's important
for artists to do, I think.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then once I share it
it's yours to interpret as you wish.
And I'm always charmed by
how people interpret it.
'Cause it's no longer about
me once they're listening,
you know?
- Yeah. 100%.
- Yeah.
- That was the coolest
part of your audience.
Like, I was literally,
there was every age,
every walk of life, every, like,
coming to your show is like
- [Alanis] Humans. Yes.
- When would we all be in
this one place at one time?
- Isn't it amazing?
- Like, it was, it's cool
though, how far you touch people.
Like, how, that broad, you
know, one of the best albums
of all time and so many great songs.
But I love, I was gonna,
I'm skipping ahead
because I'm ADHD.
- Oh, you can.
- But it's because you
said it's how you feel
like, in music,
and I love that you did
this meditation album
because you're known for lyrics right?
Or for my world you are.
- Yeah.
- And I think it's beautiful
the fact that you're now,
there's no lyrics, right?
- [Alanis] Right.
- It's all like medita-
it's been hard couple years.
- Yes. Yes.
- [Kelly] For a lot of us so, or everyone.
- Yeah.
- And it's, was that why
you decided to do it?
Because there's no lyrics,
but it's still like very,
it's you.
- It's an invitation to feel, basically.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And what I consider it in
terms of it being different
from meditation records that I adore
is that there's an invitation
to feel different things.
You don't have to just be zenned out
to listen to meditation music
in this particular case.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- There's mania and there's
rage and there's release
and there's fear.
And you know, I mean,
so much was going on.
I mean, our whole lives
there's so much going on,
I can't believe we're all still here. But.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Those two years in
particular, the lockdown eras,
I just kept thinking.
I was so inspired to begin with,
but I didn't wanna write a
record that was, you know,
beautifully naval gazing as
artists really need to do
I think.
- Yeah.
- So I wanted to create something
that would be helpful for
me in my meditative process,
but also would be a gift
on some level to people
if they want to use it
as a tool or a companion,
because sometimes when I'm in
a trauma or I'm in a flashback
or whatever I'm in.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you're triggered.
- Meditating is actually
just kind of re-traumatizing
in some ways.
There's this meditative induced
anxiety that can come up
for those of us who are
protected a lot of times.
Meditating can be too vulnerable.
- Yeah. Like being still is like, yeah.
- And hearing the voices
extra loud in your head
is not always ideal.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So sometimes music can be
a sort of gateway into it.
You feel safe, compatriotised,
and healing, yeah.
- Yeah. And I think that's magical, but.
- [Alanis] Thanks.
- Your dad gave you some advice,
and I love this 'cause it
feels like you grew up in Texas
with this advice.
So, tell everybody what that advice is
and how it's helped you.
- Yes. So when I was, as I was
stepping into the public eye
as a young creature, my dad said,
honey, there's gonna be three
ways people perceive you.
He said, the first group
of people will adore you
and you can do no wrong.
The second group of people will hate you
and you can do no right.
- [Kelly] No matter what you do, yeah.
- And then the third group of
people won't give a (beep).
(everyone laughing)
- I love that!
- And he said, that'll be
the case no matter what,
so enjoy.
- Yeah. No, but it's so freeing!
- [Alanis] And it's true!
- It's liberating to know
that no matter what I do,
no matter how people
pleasey I can be or...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Fear of rejection or please like me,
that no matter what, there's just no way.
- Yeah.
- I haven't read a comment about me
that is disparaging and cruel in 20 years.
- Oh my God! So I don't,
I don't do it either.
I think it's so,
'cause either you're gonna
wanna crawl in a hole and die.
- Right.
- Or you're gonna drink your own Kool-Aid,
and we've met them.
- Or you can drink.
- Those people. Yeah.
Or you drink... to escape.
- [Alanis] Yes. Yes. The pain.
- No, but it's, it's like it's,
or you drink your own Kool-Aid
and you think like nothing
you do is like whatever.
- Yeah, it's not that either.
- [Kelly] So it's nothing is
good. No good comes from it.
- Well, I think it's about soliciting
someone's supportive
opinion who knows you.
I'd rather have someone know me well
and tell me what my growth edge might be
and have them invite me into some behavior
that might be a little terrifying.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You know, and everyone
has their own growth edge.
One person, it might be to show up more,
another person it might be to
say no more often, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Hey!
- Hey, yeah ha.
Thank you. Wow.
- I'm like, I feel you.
So, I'm curious.
Like, what was the first
album you bought as a kid?
- "The Smurfs All Star Show".
- The Smurfs. Yes!
(everyone laughing)
- So hip.
- They escaped quite a bit.
I feel like whoever invented this...
- They escaped a lot.
- Yeah. I feel like The Smurfs too.
I feel like whoever created
that, they were on something.
- [Alanis] Shrooms.
- It was an interesting idea.
It was like "Alice in Wonderland"-ish.
I was like, what's happening?
- Yes. And super diverse. It was cool.
- Yeah. I'm just curious,
like who inspired you?
'Cause well done.
- Aw.
- Whoever did.
- I mean, so many people.
Standing on the shoulders
of giants every day.
I'm just constantly
blown away at the paper.
- Everything you say sounds like it came
from like a beautiful self
help book and I love it.
I'm like, you should write one.
I was just like, what? My growth edge?
Am I, is that my new thing?
I'm like, fine, fine.
- [Alanis] I'll do it.
- I'm gonna find my growth
edge. I'm like, what?
- Yes. Well you're in it, every day.
- I do feel like one.
I love... I love a
challenge like that though.
- [Alanis] Yeah.
- Like, growing and trying something new.
Do you love that?
- That crunch, that alchemy
of transmuting from the
horror into the inside.
I mean, it can take decades.
(audience members laughing)
- Like, even what you just
said. I just feel blessed.
I'm like, wait, what?
- You're killing me.
- Alchemy of your, I was like, what?
So, you're currently touring
and like I was telling y'all,
I'm not kidding, it's literally
possibly my favorite show
I've ever been to in my life.
Like, it was just so good.
And do you, I was just
wondering, because everyone,
you are such a lyric person.
Do you ever forget them
and just make them up?
I do.
- Of course.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes. Or there have been
moments where I'm singing
and thank the Lord, the
audience knows the lyrics,
and I'll just do that.
- You sing.
- Yeah.
'Cause I'm like, am I in
the second verse? Yeah.
I'm like, wait, what? I'm like, yeah.
- Yes.
- 'Cause sometimes, yeah.
- No, I mean it completely disappears.
- Yes. Okay.
- That happens, that's so normal.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yes.
- I just have you here
to make me feel normal.
- Okay good. My joy is to do that.
- This is actually interesting
because when this next artist,
when I heard her record,
Olivia Rodrigo, I literally
told all of y'all.
(audience cheering)
And I literally said she...
y'all are very different artists
but I listened to her
album from beginning to end
and I was like, I'm 40,
and I'm really into this.
And I was like, and it's so good.
And I feel like it's like a
different version of like you.
Like, I feel like y'all are very similar.
I feel like you're different.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] But I thought, man.
- Similar fabric.
- She had to have been, like,
influenced by you a bit.
'Cause it's, I feel
like she was that artist
that I feel like for her
generation was, like,
my generation's Alanis.
And so, is it true that
you gave her, I heard,
some kind of survival,
like road survival kit?
- She mentioned she was going on the road
and hadn't done that a lot
and I just thought, oh, okay.
- Your voice is gonna die.
- Well, yeah. And then
also there's sort of,
archetypally, constitutionally,
you're either kind of a
road dog or you're not.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think those of
us who are road dogs,
we have little tricks up our sleeve
of what to bring to
survive, for self care even.
So for me, it's about, you know,
bringing the equivalent of
my blankie everywhere I go,
you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's as simple as a pillow or...
- [Kelly] Your comforts, yeah.
- Yeah. And so I think I
mentioned in our conversation,
Olivia's and my conversation
that I would send her a care package
and I really should get on that.
- You should really (laughs)
- Yeah. Thanks for reminding me, Kelly.
- Yes.
- But I will and I can, yeah.
- No, it's just interesting
because I've never compared anyone to you.
And I was just like, wow,
she's like a younger version,
like a different version or whatever.
But anyway, so what will be
in it? What's in your comfort?
Do you have a blankie,
Linus? Like, you do?
- Anything cozy.
- Okay.
- At our house anywhere
you fall it's a mattress
or a cozy blanket.
I think I have that the hygge.
The huga, it's actually
pronounced, H Y G G E.
- [Kelly] What's that?
- Danish. It's sort of a cozy,
it's commitment to cozy basically.
- Okay.
- I'm Crasley.
- Even your blankets are cool.
What?
I'm like, mine was like target
or something, I don't know.
- [Alanis] Oh, probably cool.
- Yeah.
- No, I'm obsessed with
the idea of creating
any semblance of comfort on the road.
So it could be essential oil
sprays, meditation music.
I always have these mini altars
I throw together at the last second.
For her, let's think
what we would give her.
I mean, what would we give
her, Kelly, for survival?
- Wait, I have question.
So why do you, so like,
the mini altar situation,
is it because it makes
you feel like tranquil?
Is that, is it?
- Yeah. And it's an invitation for ritual
and actually breathing most of my life
because of anxiety and all the feelings.
- [Kelly] I think it's so important.
- I, you know, I basically
have had a shallow breath,
which sends a message to your
brain that you're in danger
and that a Saber-toothed
tiger is coming right at you.
- Yeah.
- Which it isn't.
- But it sure feels like it is.
- Yeah.
- So basically the only thing
that actually keeps me going
is being hyper present,
to the point where my
husband sometimes just goes,
can we talk about the
future for five seconds?
- Five seconds?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, I'm your husband.
- Oh!
- I'm a planner.
I just like some kind of dream out there.
I love you so much, it's
always great to see you
- Aww, you too Kelly.
- Thank you so much for coming by.
- You're amazing. Thank you.
- I love the new album,
I think it's so cool.
- Thank you.
- And it's so you, and
it's so gonna help us.
- Oh, awesome.
- So Alanis's meditation album,
"The Storm Before The Calm",
which is the raddest title ever,
is available now for pre-order
and out everywhere on June 17th.
You can also catch her on
the "Jagged Little Pill"
25th Anniversary Tour if you're smart.
You really need to go,
'cause Jessie's just pointing at herself.
We had the best time ever.
Check online for cities and dates.